[Music]
princess charlotte keeps her brother
prince george in line the subtle lesson
in royal etiquette went down on the
buckingham palace balcony as charlotte
and george joined their family to wrap
up celebrating the queen's platinum
jubilee naturally they played the
national anthem god saved the queen and
george made the mistake of putting his
hand on the balcony's ledge that's when
charlotte nudged her big bro's arm
seemingly telling him to fix his posture
[Music]
yep george quickly corrected himself by
standing up straight and putting his
arms by his side
charlotte seemed to be on mind your
manor's duty all jubilee long cameras
also caught her putting little bro louie
in check
the festivities kicked off with a
carriage ride around town
but at one point charlotte took a break
from waving to the ground and wanted
louie to follow her lead yeah she
totally grabbed his hand and put it on
his lap
earlier charlotte took charge to stop
louis from waving in their horse-drawn
carriage along with prince george their
mum the duchess of cambridge and camilla
the duchess of cornwall william and his
father prince charles got to horse guard
parade separately on horseback and in
full regalia and then during the
trooping of color ceremony prince louis
got cheeky on the balcony doing silly
faces right next to his great grand
[Music]
and charlotte she wasn't here for it the
four-year-old had the best facial
expressions as he waved wildly to the
crowd and chatted to his
great-grandmother the queen his antics
had his sister charlotte actually
scolding him at one point telling him to
pay attention
yeah the little princess is taking her
royal duties very seriously and we can't
blame her after all it was a big weekend
for her on saturday charlotte made her
first ever official royal visit a trip
to cardiff castle with george and her
parents during rehearsals for a concert
at cardiff castle charlotte tried her
hand at conducting the band as they
played we don't talk about bruno
check out charlotte looking like a total
pro conducting the musicians
[Music]
oh and kate she's one proud mama who
couldn't help but boast about her kiddos
there kate said that the seven-year-old
is practicing piano while her
eight-year-old brother is taking
electric guitar lessons
fingers crossed for a royal kiddo
musical performance the next time we see
this fam
[Music]
you